I'm Brian Bluen and I am a cup master with PAC 3285 out of Rockford, Michigan.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
After all of the preparation and all of the things that you have to do to get yourself to summer camp,
there we were. The parents had dropped off the scouts, and here we are and I look around and
I see one of my scouts. his six-year-old brother is there carrying a pair of crutches under his
arm and he's struggling to carry a big box loaded with bandages and adhesive tape and gauze. and
I look at him and I say: well, what in the world is your little brother doing here?
And the scout said: you told me to bring a first aid kid.
Kid, Get it, Not kid. Oh my,
If you must make a comment on that one. thank Frank Maynard for that. Thank you, Frank.
Hey, this is podcast number 227.. Hey,
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag, see who got in touch. Now, if you've been following things
closely, you remember last week I got a message from somebody who their unit number
happened to be the same number as the podcast and I thought, wow, well, we'll just dedicate
each number to podcasts, to the units that share that number. It'd be easy, right?
Well, Dave Klein got in touch and he said we're Troop 918..
I don't know if we can wait for you to mention us until the 918th podcast.
I hope you're still in production for that by then. I wonder how old that will make you. too old,
Dave, way too old. Thanks for being in touch, though.
Heard from Lindsay O'Rourke with PAC 316 in Santa Ana, California. She said:
I found your site at the beginning of our scouting year in fall of 2013 on Pinterest.
I believe it was your how to sleep warm while camping infographic.
Thank you for all the time you put into scouting and share with us. It's invaluable.
Love the podcast too. We just finished our first year in Cub Scouting. What a blast it was.
Well, thanks so much for getting in touch, Lindsay. I'm glad that you're finding what
we're doing useful. I did get a chance to chat with a few people this past week online.
If you go to scoutmastercgcom, keep an eye at the top of the page, because
if I'm working on things and I can manage it, I will turn on the chat feature and
that way, if you're there and I'm there. at the same time we can chat.
Well, I did get a chance to chat with some people this week, Somehow or another.
I just didn't save any of the information. So, thank you, folks,
Those of you who know that you were there and we had a chat-
I really appreciate you spending the time with me.
If the chat feature isn't on, you can leave a message, like Rob Kerrigan did from Maine.
Hello, Rob, Thanks for checking in On the blog this past week. one of the posts was about a book
that I've always had a copy of. It's called Mountaineering and the Freedom of the Hills
and it's published by a group out west called the Mountaineers. It's kind of the definitive
textbook on Mountaineering, which is admittedly not going to be applicable for a lot of us in
scouting because it's mostly about technical climbing, camping and things above the tree line
at elevation. But there's also a lot of good general information in it too. As I said in the review,
I think the books are worthy read for scouts because it gives you this philosophy of traveling
and being in the outdoors. If you have even the slightest interest in the technical aspects
of climbing and everything, it's the, like I said, the definitive textbook And if you
familiarize yourself with some of that, it may help you judge that. hey, you know what
guys? we're going to stay off that cliff. We're not going to climb there. You need better equipment
than that. We had our weekly video picks and there was a skit and skills and a song to share
with you there, So make sure to check that out. And then our infographic this week was about
what causes wilderness emergencies, And if you haven't seen that yet, I'll give you the short
answer: It's people that cause wilderness emergencies a lot more often than a sudden
change in conditions, So make sure to check that out. And then on Green Bar Life, Enoch
Highsy did a great post about how youth leaders can handle mistakes, not just in scouting,
but just in general. Good thinking from Enoch, So make sure to check out that post. Oh, and just
before we get going here, a couple of thousand of you have the Scoutmaster CG app And it's a
great way to keep the resources we create at your fingertips on a mobile device. So you
can get your app at iTunes or at Google Play, depending on which tribe you're in, right, If
you're in the Apple tribe or the Android tribe, we're equal opportunity. You can get the app for any
mobile device. I'm going to also remind you about the backer program. If you're finding
the podcast and the other resources that we create are useful for you, you can return
the favor by becoming a backer. The funds that we get from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing all of the different resources we create And we want to keep freely
available for Scouters all over the world. Let me take this opportunity to thank
Tripp Wycoff, Robert Causer and Danny van Pelt for becoming backers this past week. It means
a great deal And we really do appreciate the support. This week in Scout Master Ship in
seven minutes or less, we're going to talk a little bit about outdoor leadership And then
we have some email questions to answer and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less?
So let me ask you this: Is there a really a difference between outdoor leadership
and leadership in other situations? To my mind, everything we do in scouting
kind of hinges on how you answer that question. I think I shared this a while back, but during a
Weeblos visit several months ago, I had one question that kind of threw me for a loop and
that was: you know, my boy doesn't really like to go camping or the outdoors very much. Is there
anything else in scouting you know that he can do? Do you have a program for that? And I was a
little taken aback and I had to explain that no, not really, because it's scouting. you know,
It's kind of like if you showed up at a football meeting to join a baseball team or something.
this is what we do, We're outside, We go outside, We go camping, We do the things that scouts do.
And it gets me to thinking about this question. So our scouts go and they exercise leadership in
the out of doors And what's. is there any major difference between that and that kind of business
management style leadership that we're probably more familiar with in our professional and
business lives? I think there's a big difference. Outdoor or scouting leadership is different, and
understanding this difference is one key to being a very effective scouter. Now
why do you think corporations invest time and resources in things like ropes courses and
leadership retreats? Because the immediacy required by outdoor leadership is an excellent
way to study and learn leadership skills. Outdoor leadership affords direct, immediate
feedback, Results of the decisions you make and the actions you take are almost instantly
apparent. on a ropes course or on a camping trip, Results of actions and decisions in the workplace.
well, we all know they may take days or weeks or months or even years to resolve themselves,
But you know when you're actually taking action and you're outdoors on a camping trip or a hike
or on a ropes course or any one of those types of activities. the feedback's pretty instant,
isn't it? The other comparison I would make is the immediacy of the goals that are involved
In most of the situations in our professional lives, in business or management,
the goals are going to be relatively long-term and they're going to require
long analysis and implementation. In outdoor leadership situations, the goals are short-term
and they're very pressing and they need to be addressed right away. When it's time to set up
camp or prepare a meal or take measures against an impending storm, there's not a whole lot of
time for careful analysis of the situation. Immediate action is required. I think also, when
we're outdoors and when we're doing the things that scouts do, there are fewer distractions
and outside influences. Outdoor leadership situations are a lot less prone to getting
distracted by, you know, the other parts of life And outside influence. because of their
immediacy, outdoor leadership situations are a lot less prone to being getting distracted
or being influenced by issues outside of what's happening right then and there. So outdoor leadership
has to be immediate and definitive to respond to changing conditions. Changes in our professional
lives or the business world can be a lot slower and in the outdoors there are going to be fewer
options and we're going to have less time to study or implement them. So there's obviously a
lot of value in taking management people into a situation that eliminates outside influences,
requires fast analysis and goal setting- kind of telescopes. the amount of time it takes to get
results- Belaying a fellow employee on a ropes course- is a direct allegory of the actual day-to-day
leadership that happens in a business environment. but it's much more immediate Now because we're
so familiar with the way that it works. in our professional lives, in business, in industry,
we take that management science and we impose it on scouting sometimes And I think when we
do that we miss unique opportunities that outdoor leadership offers our scouts. You know,
in any context met with unfamiliar situations we're going to apply what we know. but scouting
outdoors differs significantly from running a business. The challenge is studying that
difference and instead of adopting business management kind of skills to scouting, devote
the time to learning and developing the skills of outdoor leadership. And the distinction
between the two is nothing new. Baden Powell talked about this. it's been talked about broadly
in scouting for the last century. That kind of business-ified scouting is all too common Business,
like agendas and minutes and parliamentary procedure and schedules and written plans.
they can be useful. but let's remember there are means to an end rather than an end in
themselves. If we're not careful, business-ifying scouting can kind of sap the energy and
immediacy out of things. Advancement loses a connection to the outdoors if we kind of
business-ify its simple aims and camping can become kind of a drudgery if we stray too
far from the moment at hand. Immediate results and immediate goals, fewer distractions,
fewer outside influences and immediate responsiveness to really ever-changing
situations make outdoor leadership exciting and active and fun. Scouts who learn
leadership in the outdoors really develop lifelong skills that they can apply in any
context. Business management and outdoor leadership share parallels and common skills,
but the differences are more important than similarities And it's something to think about,
isn't it? So if you find yourself kind of business-ifying scouting,
think about what the differences are and get back to where we're really aimed, And that's
getting outdoors, And the leadership that happens outdoors is what really benefits our scouts.
E-mail, that is folks, And here's an answer to one of your e-mails.
Well, I got several e-mail questions this past week. Let's see The first one.
we're withholding the name at the sender's request, At several council events. I've been told that the
Guide to Safe Scouting is just a guide. It's not really actual hard and fast rules, and that some
activities can be done at a council or district event that aren't allowed at a pack or a troop
level. As an example, there was Tomahawk throwing by Weebelow's Scouts at our council Weebelow's
Woods event. I read the Guide to Safe Scouting and it lumps Tomahawk throwing in with the
other shooting sports And it only includes it as an approved activity for Boy Scouts and Venturers.
So my question is: is the Guide to Safe Scouting really just a guide and permits councils to
make adjustments based on their program needs? That doesn't seem to be right to me. I really
enjoy your podcasts. I have long commutes and they keep me informed and entertained. Well,
I think the first and most important thought here is: the Guide to Safe Scouting is not just
a guide. I think that's flat wrong. There are plenty of definitive statements in it that indicate
you know, these are not just ideas for you to adapt, These are rules. This is the way that
things are. That being said, I want you to know that there are indeed a few rules that differ
for unit level and council or district level activities, And you've hit on a good example
of one. For example, archery and BB guns are allowed for Cubs and Weeblos at council or district
events with certified, trained supervision. While I can't find any verbiage to confirm it, I suspect
that the Tomahawk throwing probably comes under the same rules for BB guns and archery for Weeblos
at a council or a district level event. I actually held a shooting sports certification
from the BSA for a number of years and I trained folks for day camp and cub camp archery a few times.
Back when I was involved in that, we didn't have the whole Tomahawk throwing thing going on. I don't
think that the issue necessarily is that your local folks are inventing rules. There are
different sets of rules based on the activity, the age in the setting. Now, before I get any
further, whenever we're faced with policy questions or questions about the rules, especially those
that affect the safety of scouts. we owe it to each other to do our level best to get it right,
Because the rules and regulations are there for two reasons: safety and the aims of the program.
And I know a lot of people are listening in who aren't members of the BSA, who are in other places
in the world. Whenever we talk about this type of thing, I'm giving you my opinion based on my
research and best knowledge that I have. But, as always, you go and you find the resources
too and you read them and talk to your local officials and make sure that I've got it right,
And if you find that I don't, you know, get in touch and let me know. Robin Bridges got in touch
this week and said: do you have an opinion on allowing boys to bring a cell phone to a camp
out or to summer camp? Wow, Robin, I'm on the internet. I have an opinion about everything. Come on,
Listen. I look at it this way: A cell phone is a tool like a pocket knife or an axe or a
saw, And scouts have to learn how to use any tool like that responsibly. Every once in a while
in our troop we have a discussion about using cell phones responsibly, And we trust the scouts
to do just that And you know to a large extent they don't disappoint us. Now they will make
mistakes And every once in a while somebody may try to get away with something, but they
use their cell phones responsibly almost all of the time. If you go back a number of years to
when, when cell phones started spreading into the world of kiddom, you know- and not just
adults having them, but kids having them too- we went through a whole lot of changes and
trying to figure out exactly how to deal with them and everything. And they were kind of new
in the hands of children And children didn't quite know how to manage them And parents
didn't quite know how to manage them And scouts didn't quite know how to manage them. But
now it's so every day. you know that. I think most people understand how to use these things
responsibly And scouts will do it. It's kind of ingrained in the culture. at this point, Do
you hear stories of people using the tools irresponsibly? Well, of course, But I think
we, if you have a general agreement with your scouts that so long as they're responsible
using any tool like a pocket knife, like a cell phone, like an ax, like a saw that then they're
permitted to carry them and use them. I want to say that I don't think it's a great idea to have
a list of rules or prohibitions concerning this type of thing, but just resolve difficulties on
an individual basis as they arise. And I want to talk about that for a moment because I think
it's important. For instance, we have the Totenship card is a way for scouts to familiarize
themselves with the responsible use of tools and knives and axes So they get recognized for
their knowledge and they get recognized as a responsible person by having that card and
presented properly. I think it's a great idea and a great program. but but it can kind of just
totally go off the rails. If you Google Totenship and see what you come up with,
you're going to find really extensive lessons, plans and tests and the wrong-headed and
silly idea that scouts are supposed to police all of these rules and things and clip the corners
off Totenship cards to ding scouts who don't know the rules, And there's big discussions on whether
or not a scout can even use a pocket knife if he doesn't have his Totenship card on his person,
And I think it's just wrong-headed and silly. You know there's a whole lot of things like
this, where scouts tend to kind of turn scouting into some kind of criminal justice system
with lists of laws and sanctions and they want to hold court and you know, it's just a little
overheated. I think what we do in these situations is we take our guidance from the scout oath and
law, which are aspirational statements, not a list of prohibitions. The scout law doesn't say a
scout never lies. It says a scout is trustworthy. And that's the spirit of the thing. If we
trust scouts to do the right thing, they almost always will, And when they don't,
we work with the individual difficulty. We don't consult the scout criminal code and file an
indictment and hold a trial and sentence scouts to sanctions. If our main aim is building character,
that character is based on an internal standard that we want to build in our scouts. And they
are going to make mistakes and they're going to step off of the reservation and that's fine.
We actually want that to happen, because then we have the opportunity to approach these things and
call on that internal standard and strengthen it and build it. And that's what we do. We counsel
and mentor and cajole and we work with scouts one at a time to build on that thing. So I went
a little far afield in my answer there. but I think it's important when we're dealing with
the ideas of trust and responsibility that we're building that into character. We're not
just imposing it and we're not going to manage that by the imposition of some kind of- you know-
system of rules and sanctions and things like that. We're going to manage it by thinking about
individual scouts and working with them. Here's another anonymous email. I'm a den leader for a
group of first year weeblos and I like to start moving them into the direction of the patrol
system. How would I best go about doing that? We have 11 boys in the den and that's a pretty
big number, but I don't have any other adults willing to be a weeblos den leader. It seems
to be working fine this way. Do you think I should break them into two patrols, with me
as the sole adult leader, And then how would we go about dividing them up? Thanks for your
website and podcast. They've really helped me change, So I know how to better lead like a
scout or should. Well, thanks for being in touch And I'm always happy to hear that
people get something out of the podcast and the and the blog. 11 is a big number,
but I got to tell you I had 18 weeblos in my den. That was quite a time. It was only a
one year program way back when I was much younger, So I made it out alive.
You know, getting weeblos engaged in leadership is going to be great fun, as long as you go
slowly and incrementally and you respond to their level of ability and interest step by step.
There'll be times where you take three steps forward and one back, just like we do in a
Boy Scout troop, but you're going to be moving forward nonetheless. You're going to do a lot
of the leading. You'll be up front giving directions and making things happen and
making plans, And that's fine. What you want to do is look for opportunities to
gradually involve the weeblos in doing a lot of what you do. It's like riding a bike.
The first step is a lot of support and close supervision And you'll eventually find you
can stand back and watch a lot of the time. You know, first year weeblos are in fourth grade
and very small things mean a lot to a fourth grader: holding the flag, standing in front of the line,
helping lead the game, handing things out. You know, those little things is where you begin,
And then you work from there and you build on those small successes with a lot of encouragement,
but they're all going to respond to these opportunities and, more importantly,
to the way that you encourage them. As for breaking the big group into smaller groups,
well, I think they'll show you whether or not they need to do this. It may work in some instances
and not for others. There may be activities where you want to have two smaller groups, and that's
fine. So let those groups be fluid and change as the situation demands or encourages. If they
get it in their heads that they want to make two different patrols, well, fine, let them do it.
And as far as how they're going to divide it up, they know better than you do
who their friends are and who they're going to get along with, And it may not be,
you know, a group of five and a group of six. it may be a group of four and a group of seven
or something like that. But pay attention to friendships. They'll be happy And, like I said,
they'll have a pretty good idea of how to divide up into a couple of groups. Now I'll tell you.
I think that, more than anything else at this age. these weeblos need a plenty of time to run
around hollering Because, if I remember correctly when I was a weeblos den leader, that's what they
seem to enjoy most. So give them plenty of time to find their own way. watch and listen to them
carefully And soon you'll see opportunities for leadership and small pieces here and there,
And pretty soon they'll begin to see the opportunities themselves. Now I really
hope that helps. It's kind of fuzzy advice, but it's awfully hard to reduce things like this to
a three step process or a list of five things you can do. The whole enterprise is more like
gardening than anything else. You create the right conditions, you plant the seeds, you water them,
you pull the weeds and you see what happens. And finally, this email from Jim Gilligy,
who's a scout master with troops 17 in Mansfield, Massachusetts. he said it looks like our
83 year old council will be merging with another council in the very near future.
I know it's not the end of the world and the change is inevitable and that
scouting will go on, But do you have any advice on the transition? I look to the good that can
come from this, but I can't help but feel that there may be less important out of unit youth
involvement in leadership positions, on a national youth leadership training staff or a camp staff
or lodge officer positions. Well, Jim, I'm sure that, as you say, there's going to be up and
downsides to any kind of thing like this. It's big change, Councils merge and it can cause some
friction and difficulty And observing this happen locally, I saw people kind of polarized
into two tribes. There was the supporters of the merger and the detractors of the merger.
It can get downright silly and unscout, like at times, the attitudes and the positions that
adults hold. So I would say that big changes like this have a lot of potential to distract
us from the mission right From what we're supposed to be doing as scouters. So my best advice
is: don't get caught up too much in the controversy and keep on keeping on And when the controversy
confronts you to be encouraging, be positive. I would think that any of the youth opportunities
you spoke of above the unit level are going to remain available at basically the same ratio
you're experiencing now. There are actual policies that dictate the staff to participant ratios
for things like a national youth leader training course or a summer camp program,
And OA lodges are going to install officers and staff their executive committees at ratios that
make service viable. So honestly, that doesn't worry me too much. You know it's likely we're
going to see more mergers. It makes sense. I find it interesting that we haven't already seen this
as more of a national trend. The growth of technology has made a lot of the things that
a local council does kind of redundant, And I know we've all seen changes with the way that
that goes, And so I would probably expect more than fewer mergers in the future. But that's
just my opinion. Hey, if you have a question or you want to hear my opinion-
because I'm always willing to offer an opinion- you can get in touch with me and you're going
to find out how to do that in just a moment. You've been listening to the 227th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast. Here's how to keep in touch. Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and
make sure you join the several thousand folks who have subscribed to receive updates to the
blog by email And you can get the Scoutmaster CG app, as I said earlier, on Google Play or in
the iTunes app store and have it all right there on your mobile device. You can experience
the wonders of Scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Join the 6,000 folks who, like us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook, Tweet along with the chorus of
just over a thousand tweeters on Twitter and pin the Pultritudinous pictures proffered publicly
with 1,600 other prolific pinners on Pinterest. Watch us, if you dare, at Scoutmaster CG on
YouTube and join the 400 odd folks who form the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle on Google Plus.
But maybe it just can't face Facebook. Maybe the very thought of Twitter makes you better.
You tell me you ain't got no interest in Pinterest. Is it that you just don't put the you in YouTube or
you feel like you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus? Is that what's bugging you, Bunky?
That was Eddie Lawrence, the old philosopher. Eddie's gone now, but he was a comedian who
recorded a lot of great comedy bits, and the old philosopher was one of them, And that's
actually where I got the whole thing about Bunky right. So no extra charge there, folks.
Is that what's bugging you, Bunky? You can zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
You can email me, Clark Green, with your comments and your questions at clarkatscoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom. Did you know? the Scoutmaster blog and podcast are not official
publications of any scouting organization, including the Boy Scouts of America. They're not endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America or any other scouting organization either.
It's just me talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to my fellow
Scouters and have a little bit of fun along the way. And speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time, everyone.